hello everyone and welcome to some more
rapid action un leaches in the previous
game well I made two two games in one
video uh the second game wasn't really
all that impressive uh so we are going
to try to be as uh as concentrated as
possible and that means we will play the
Scandinavian defense no we're not no uh
I've played that too many times let's go
for the for the Sicilian and let's go
for
the for the hyper accelerated dragon
uh never done any real research on this
but uh yeah I I did play this with white
against uh black so shouldn't be
shouldn't be much
different okay so he will move the queen
then I will move the Knight and then
that's pretty much where my theory
knowledge
ends okay so I've never seen this
Retreat I've only seen uh this
Retreat so let's see how to how to to
deal with this this uh Queen D1 stops
the usual advancement of the Knight to
D5 so I'm I guess I'm going to play
Knight to E4 yeah makes
sense and if Bishop D3 just D5 yeah
makes again makes sense I get my Bishop
into the
game uh put the bishop on G7 castle Yeah
so uh well well I do prefer the
Scandinavian I thought okay let's let's
give this a try as
well
okay you can play
that uh do we have
any do we have any ideas and maybe to
sacrifice a pawn here with something
like Bishop F5 is this
something
uh yeah maybe it's not but it looks It
looks
interesting I'm guessing I will I will
either win back this Pawn or this Pawn
so
why
not yeah with maybe some Queen E4 or
queen to D5 action and
uh yeah why
not let's go here he might go Knight C3
if I just attack him with the
queen uh yeah let's Castle first not in
a
rush
Bishop G4 also interesting maybe to ruin
his King set a little bit but after
Bishop to G4 you could just move the
queen but then we take the Knight and
then we win the pawn back so this is
sort of the simplest way to win back
material and then we play E6 and
probably probably if you ask the engine
it will be a Zer
0.0 yeah okay so he goes for that as we
as as we thought he
would okay but then yeah then
he will put pressure on this so I will
have to take with the bishop okay
still if Bishop
H6 yeah he goes back I go
back nothing to it
um yeah let's go here or do we go here
do we go here do we go here do we go
here let's go here and pretend we're not
attacking his Bishop maybe he falls for
it yeah no he
doesn't uh now how do I want to place my
Rooks that's the question that's the
real question do I want something like
Rook E8 and then something like this or
do I just want to fight for the defile
as he will put Rooks on the defile yeah
probably probably this is a bit too
optimistic probably it
is
H let's just go
E6
okay this is now very interesting um
yeah now let's uh now now we could
actually offer the the B Pawn for the
for this Pawn Yeah if he
wants if not then maybe we can get our
Knight to D3 put a rook on d8 we'll see
what he
does
yeah I don't think he'll take doesn't
really do all that much for
him okay so he goes
here yeah makes
sense makes
sense uh
uh yeah let's put pressure on the B
Pawn and then we we control the then we
control the D
file orry let me just check something
real
quickly
okay now the Knight is pretty much stuck
here guarding the pawn Pawn so let's go
after
it let's go after it okay so he
defends uh and now let's claim the now
let's claim the the
defile so he cannot play Rook to
D1 and next we
go maybe even something like this but
now it could be could be too dangerous
yeah he does have all sorts of Knight
jumps uh first we're going to play B6
probably yeah we'll see what he
plays yeah
okay it's
fair just REM maneuver the queen go
after the pawn
here now his Knight is kind of stuck
here for the moment
yeah okay he goes for
that can't play Knight C6 and sort of
threaten to win the
Knight although it doesn't do
much
yeah if he if he moves the queen then
I'm just going to have to trade without
actually accomplishing much so not not
the
best
[Music]
yeah we're going to REM maneuver that
Knight he's going to move the queen now
of course but doesn't
matter
it will be interesting uh I mean this uh
this hyper accelerated Dragon stuff is
very very tricky and U you you can go
wrong very easily uh but we're going to
check after the game if if there's
anything we could have done
better okay so now if he doesn't do
anything just E5 like we said okay so of
course he plays that but now this is
just a blunder we can play Rook captur
and that's it yeah he he blundered that
unfortunately happens
sometimes okay uh it's a very short game
now we could also play another one like
in the previous
video uh I was not expecting uh such a
such a quick
game okay so he does have
this yeah maybe celebrating a bit too
early
maybe yeah but
okay
H maybe celebrated a bit too early but
still I feel like this is uh
like this is
enough the bishop here will be very
strong if I can get those pawns up the
board
yeah guarding this attacking this we can
even uh play E5 to to guard the bishop
and then maybe some B5
A4 yeah pretty pretty good stuff here
okay so he goes after the B Pawn we're
going to defend it uh but also we're
just threatening to win the
queen and yeah or maybe maybe E5 is a
bit too
optimistic
okay very
nice
h
yeah totally missed that move but still
I I I I I think that we are better
here okay so attacking The Rook makes
sense of
course going to go here
yep go
here now he does have this which is
quite annoying yeah he doesn't want to
go for it very
interesting y okay so it's going to be a
full game definitely I celebrated too
early which I don't I don't think he
actually saw that move I actually
thought I actually think he blundered
and then he figured out a way out of it
uh but okay okay so attacking my Rook
here of course let's go
here so we just have to make sure that
everything is defended Queen defends The
Rook okay this is now a queen
blunder
yeah
this is a queen blunder however he plays
it but okay it's still going to be two
Rooks versus my queen uh is is is this
the best let me just check if I have
anything better so yeah we can win the
queen but maybe there's something
better yeah if I can somehow connect
with his if I I could connect with a
check with the Rook that'd be
better uh but I can't so we will take
the take the
queen yeah nothing
better and now we push our pawns so I I
think it's going to be too hard for him
to organize some sort of a Counterattack
here even though he has the two
Rooks uh but we'll
see we'll see
okay so he goes
forward makes
sense okay so H just create a pass Pawn
here and I do want to play F5 of course
I do but first we have to hide the king
first we have to hide the king okay
so let's go after the
pawn yeah definitely celebrated a bit
too early there but uh he retaliated by
blundering the queen that's very nice
okay
so uh his works are still connected
which uh we of course don't like okay
but now we'll defend the pawn and even
though he can give one check and my king
on H6 will be very
vulnerable uh I will have all sorts of
checks so he will not be in time to
Checkmate
me
okay so so he disconnects his Rooks
that's very
brave that's very brave of
him yeah
that's okay so let's take this one so
we're out of any danger
and then we're going to go after now he
has to start connecting Rooks otherwise
I'm just going
to otherwise I'm just going to Checkmate
him uh now we're sort of getting into
the territory of uh of it being possible
for me to give up the queen for The Rook
as I'm I I do I do have four
pawns uh but I don't think it will be
necessary yeah okay so he goes for
that go for a nice check here and then
we start
advancing yeah okay let's go
forward yeah he can threaten with every
move but then I just move the queen and
move the pawn pretty much
it
yeah okay so what's the what's the
cleanest way to do it
that's pretty
clean okay and we get a
queen so he's still not going to resign
uh we we will have to push all the
way okay let's
go yeah let's just take that
Rook if he does does not resign we are
going to promote all all all all three
of our
pawns there we
go there we go okay let's not
uh let's go
here go
here now it's uh even possible for him
to get some sort of a uh to get some
sort of
a draw if I if I manage to blunder this
uh but uh yeah it's it's hard to choose
uh for which Checkmate to go
to all right we're going to go here
we're going to go here is this is this
is this it yeah this mate in one
okay so very nicely done and uh yeah
we're going to analyze it just to make
sure because up until that point I think
we were doing really okay uh okay so
this is uh let me just check this queen
D1 move so not the oh yeah I forgot
about that yeah because uh I I've had
similar things happen to me but yeah you
can actually take the pawn here and then
give a check and then win the Knight
back so that's why Queen to D1 is bad uh
if any of you will encounter it but okay
I didn't go for it and now it's
immediately equal yeah that was uh that
that's a shame so giving up this Pawn
you know for some counterplay was not uh
it was not bad it was okay as I I can
win the pawn back easily so this is all
pretty pretty drawish now uh pretty
drawish stuff
yeah okay so capturing maybe a little
bit better but nothing
spectacular uh still a draw still a draw
still a draw yeah this is all fine fine
fine Queen C2 yeah
uh so capturing the queen is the
preferred one but even Rook captures is
still drawsh territory 0 point 0.2 so
nothing spectacular here yeah we've
played everything correctly here yeah so
a queen trade would be better here but
yeah still
0.0 maybe slightly better for black
now uh yeah Rook D6 yeah now it's
definitely better for black and with
Queen t7 yeah he blunders the game uh so
yeah it was never never were bad for
black Al although maybe trading Queens
was a little bit
better yeah and objectively it is
winning because I have two many pawns
and okay it's really no point in
analyzing that that any further uh but
yeah okay it was a it was a nice game uh
maybe if you guys like the the hyper
accelerator Dragon you can also try it
but uh we're going to keep it to one
game per video as it's already 20
minutes for this one but yeah I hope you
hope you got something out of it and
maybe it helps you in your own games uh
thank thank you all I will see you soon
uh have an excellent rest of your
day